reading movie insists on an orgy of
evidence that Michael Myers grew up in a
broken home take that damn thing off
you know what makes horror movies really
good delving into the killer's home life
when he was a kid and getting into the
deep psychological roots of mass murder
bullies ever do is get into fights and
talk about fights they got in they have
no other interests or character traits
and years of spy kidding really set this
kid down the wrong path angry bully who
wants to beat up Michael Myers somehow
doesn't see Michael Myers staring at him
as he walks right towards him it's hard
to believe that anyone in this family
would concern themselves with carving a
jack-o-lantern for Halloween we have to
arrange KITT Michael Myers the damage
stripper mom a baby
the slutty daughter and william forsythe
who's carving pumpkins no one that's who
despite the newspaper clipping
advertising a topless show the strip
club apparently has a tops on policy and
this movie isn't pg-13 and Sheri moon
zombie has never been shy about this
kind of thing before
just kind of curious that's all
meanwhile the movie has no problem
showing grown-up Jenny from Forrest Gump
topless or grown-up Jamie Lloyd from
Halloween form five topless or well
let's face it everyone except Sheri moon
zombie is topless in this movie you know
considering the killing spree that
Michael Myers goes on after he eats this
candy the candy corn the circus peanut
it's easy to blame the sugar or at the
very least the substandard Halloween
treats I've almost completely forgotten
about the abuse neglect and the fact
that he's already killed a guy at this
point plus there was this ominous
warning from his mother before she left
too much candy and all he remembers
later is his costume in his candy hey
that's creepy what the fuck are you
looking at I don't know about that Sam a
long-haired blonde ten-year-old with
dead eyes I think I'd go to great
lengths avoiding this kid just on
instinct has anyone else been admitted
into this entire Hospital yeah let's
just turn our back on the psycho killer
while he has eating utensils in front of
him and why do they even let this kid
have real eating pencils anyway this kid
is eating like corn peas and bread does
he need a metal fork for and even if
he's eating steak in 30 seconds of slow
motion screaming who the fuck does the
hiring at Smith's Cove sanitarium anyway
also I guess no explanation needs to be
made for drunken rapey rednecks but I
really don't understand what's gained by
performing this task and michael maier
self I mean why don't you just go ahead
and add auto-erotic asphyxiation to the
mix so while Michael is killed only
people we wanted to see dead anyway
you almost kind of root for this crazy
bastard okay except for now when you
kill Danny Trejo it's personal every
character that we know he's going to die
later and an insufferable dick when they
enter the picture I mean is this
moviemaking murder cathartic force maybe
we're the real monsters now you're
fuckin with my head Rob Zombie flipping
through a porno mag while taking a
number two you don't want a boner while
sitting on a public toilet dude in case
you didn't know Michael is doing
something really really violent the
camera shakes on every impact so it's
easy to figure out Michael doesn't seem
the kind of killer to care about a new
outfit really but I guess there's still
some part of him that cares about taking
a black man's clothes for his own Laurie
Strode who we know is Michael Myers
younger sister all grown up solves the
nature vs. nurture debate with
inappropriate bagel behavior how could
she
that movie isn't for another three years
in Benicio del Toro was Porto Rican the
candy corn kid Ruby continues conceit
that either sugar or third-rate candy
makes you crazy wait he had time to bury
all this the floorboards right after he
killed his family seriously what kind of
important brochure or document needs to
be placed in the mail slot at the old
Myers home
who was this for and why would it need
to be delivered here hey thought my
porch lights are not on and there are no
Halloween decorations around and I've
got machine guns attached to my
sprinkler system everything about my
house says go away this movie must be
absolutely required to have a
jack-o'-lantern in almost every scene
what's with these hot chicks banging
guys way below their pay grade first
Michaels older sister and now the
hottest cheerleader in the school
Haddonfield must have like zero hot guys
but you'd think this chick would be
nailing a college dude or an assistant
professor at Northwestern or something
hey cool kill it's almost exactly like
that one from another horror movie I saw
a long time ago remember the name anyway
Michaels knife isn't nearly long enough
to pin this guy to the wall and even if
it was his weight would make this morbid
arts and crafts project come tumbling
down Wow Michael got every detail of
this ruse down pat except the boyfriend
was bringing up a six-pack not just want
beer Michael Myers is a dick - other
dudes girl
friends after killing their boyfriends
in case you were wondering about where
dr. Sam Loomis got his gun in the first
Halloween here's a completely necessary
scene showing you the ins and outs of
the purchasing process also Illinois has
a 72 hour waiting period to possess a
handgun after purchase but Loomis found
the one store that doesn't give a fuck
I'm not sure why Michael came to this
house how did he know where Annie was
babysitting tonight I don't see how he
figured this out or even had time to
figure it out he was camped out at his
old house he killed the naughty couple
he came over to the strode residence and
killed boys parents now he just
magically shows up at this random house
where Annie is I read the sheriff
apparently keeps a book he hates sitting
around on his desk all day just in case
the author shows because monsters sell
books the disbelieving Sheriff is a
cliche in movies but never with so much
evidence being ignored the news of what
Michael did at the sanitarium apparently
still isn't big news not even enough to
put this hometown sheriff on alert hello
you've reached thrillin residence ironic
hat the answering machine message when
things are not happy cliche let's go
the sheriff is now worried that
something is wrong because the strode x'
didn't pick up their phone even with the
back story he provides later somebody
not answering their phone isn't that big
of a deal why does the blond-haired kid
have to come pick Annie up to drive her
a distance she could easily walk and
already did walk why didn't Annie's
boyfriend just come to pick Annie and
Lindsay up when they were carrying all
that Dover
I mean Lindsay already knows when Annie
and Paul are gonna do so he isn't some
mystery to her does Annie ever lock the
door even when she's having dirty filthy
sex with her boyfriend this is the
second time Michael has just wandered
into the house without breaking in you
probably will say crazy things under
duress but Lori tells Lindsay to run
home and call the police they are
actually in Lindsey's home right now
which and I know child psychologist
might confuse a kid especially in a
traumatic situation but she ends up
going to the little boy Tommy's house
anyway and then doesn't appear to
remember why she even came here how long
is it gonna take to get this about
they're in Haddonfield does it take ten
minutes to get anywhere we've seen
people walking all over the neighborhood
and to school and less time and you've
been driving forever apparently no one
in the entire neighborhood is at home
tonight or cares about someone screaming
in the middle of the street and this is
after the little girl did it two minutes
ago
Michael was keeping excellent pace with
the limping and screaming Laurie before
but apparently he stopped for a snack
during the chase and it took him forever
to catch back up
so I guess Lindsay did indeed call the
cops but once they got all the
information why didn't they go to
Lindsay's house you know where there are
actual dead and injured people remember
Laurie called the police - wouldn't the
police lumped those two calls together
and realized they needed to go to the
murder house but the cops show up here
for some reason just in time to be
slaughtered by Michael Myers what the
it's Michael waiting for this whole time
does he actually waiting around for the
cops to show up before he broke into his
bathroom Laurie was screaming her lungs
out in Michael's arms before but I guess
she fainted between this shot in the
next shot aliv I know there still isn't
anyone who cares about anything in this
neighborhood even after the cops showed
up and there was even more screaming
seriously your first target was his
shoulder I guess it's possible - the
Myers family had a random pool in the
backyard but how do you miss this
monstrosity even if you're running for
your life clearly everyone in this
neighborhood went to Chicago for the
night and Haddonfield no-one hears you
scream when hears gunshots if you think
Michael has some kind of special
boogeyman wouldn't you wait until the
authorities showed up before leaving him
to the pool even if you think he's a
hundred percent dead okay now that
you've been let go and there's this
whole big wide world for you to run into
you decide to go up the stairs
sure yeah based on a feeling you might
have heard of and never need to be
remained and I want to look it up
sometime
beyond useless eight millimeter films of
young Michael Myers doing stuff
three of them they're also window
decoration one on top of the fridge plus
decoration on the fridge not the same
fridge same ones with two more
decorations also there's one on a cereal
box faintly on top of the fridge and
while a newspaper on the kitchen table
peeking out has another one behind
william forsythe palace river newspaper
clipping six decorations on the TV
plastic one on the chair by the front
door plastic one it could be the same
one from earlier but any different scene
someone walking behind Michael with a
different plastic one yet another kid
with a plastic one to click paint three
ones in the front yard - decorations on
the house and one more plastic one for
candy decoration mask in Michael Myers
cell on the right side preparation on
window real one on the filing cabinet
and blurry decoration on filing cabinet
- in the yard
plastic one on the porch who already
counted four in the other yard another
one on a forge almost hidden to the
right of the door decorations on front
porch steps six in the corner behind
Michael Myers three of the house across
the street that one plastic one in the
band real one on the table behind the
couch three papercraft ones in the
gunstore background decoration behind
car rear view mirror to a shelf
two on the stairs one orange christmas
light one in the bushes real one in
foreground decorative centerpiece on
table real one on table two decorations
in the background and another small real
one shows up on the table decoration in
real one is the camera passes plastic
woman decoration as it goes further by
stick on the outdoor table 2 in the
background Annie carrying on full-blown
ones in the yard one porch Smashville on
the street glowing decoration next door
smash one dead guy background kitchen 2
on the porch one next door to more the
horses lorry runs for her life in the
Myers death trap during credits before
casting during credits before danny
trejo credit one before ooh tokyo credit
one for william forsythe credit
so I can say fuck buffer with me
these eyes do not see what you and I see
behind these eyes one finds only
blackness the fingers you can use to
dial our Tunes that to obtain a special
tiling one please smash the keypad with
your palm now